look the reality is it's been a very
bitter and divisive contest following on
from boris johnson being thrown out
basically by his own party and that
tends to leave quite a lot of black bad
blood there i think the reality is that
though the one thing that will be in liz
truster's favor is the general
election's probably a couple of years
away and that is really going to
concentrate minds if there's a real
danger of labor really pushing through
and winning a general election i think
that will concentrate a lot of minds in
terms of unity
yeah and how likely is that because of
course as i was put into tomorrow
there is a feeling that whatever cabinet
does come in place could well be one of
the most right-wing sort of cabinets
that we've seen in the conservative
government
i think that's right i think there will
be a lot of people in the conservative
party who are nervous about the economic
policies that are being taken here and
there's going to have to be a big
persuasion job i think part of the job
in number 10 particularly the chief of
staff role is to actually liaise with
mps and make sure that there's proper
communication going on and i think that
that part of the operation is going to
be absolutely crucial making sure that
number 10 is very very clearly talking
to backbenchers is very clear on where
the issues are and making sure that
there are relations
the chief of staff we think might well
be wendy morton for um
liz trust i mean how do you expect the
uh operation in there to be run
differently if his liz trusts who does
win
i think that what she's got to do is
very clearly after three years of boris
johnson he had a number of iterations of
number 10 and all of them really were a
bit of a mess they struggled to actually
have unity what she's got to do is make
clear that this is our strategy these
are our goals everybody needs to know
exactly what their position is and they
all need to be pushing in the same
directions previous number tens one of
the things that we did when david
cameron was in charge was make sure that
we were very very clear on message we
all stuck together we didn't brief
against each other what you've tended to
see in recent years in politics is an
endless stream of commentary a running
commentary on what the government's
doing i think that they need to stop
doing that and stop being in a position
where they're effectively campaigning
all the time and demonstrating that
they're governing the number one exam
question that they face at the moment is
what are you going to do about the
energy crisis how are you going to get
struggling britain's through this winter
and they need to have a complete laser
focus on that
and
are you the one who came up craig oliver
with this idea of the trust being a
cameron cutie you remember that from
2012
i'm afraid i would never say anything so
sexist liz trustee you know it's a
bright capable engaged person she's a
woman in her own right you'd never say
such a thing about a man i think you
know no pretty offensive um look she
looked but sorry craig oliver the point
i'm making is that was the name of the
list of women who were who were put
forward wasn't it they yeah
they were called cameron
are you a director of comms i don't want
to no look i'm sorry i'd love to think
that as director of comms that i could
control you guys and get you to come up
with all the phrases i wanted of course
i'd never use such a phrase and i never
would it's a terrible phrase but anyway
let's go down that rabbit hole she's a
capable woman she's clear she's made it
to the top of the the conservative party
she's going to be prime minister she's
got the toughest entree of all time uh
and it's going to be an extraordinary
challenge for her the big difference for
her is the difference between going from
campaign mode to governing and she's got
to demonstrate i would say very very
quickly that she's got a grip on the
energy crisis and that she's going to
make that work
and i thought from you on the diversity
that we're seeing at the top of the
conservative party now
the third female prime minister um we've
got um black people in serious offices
of state as well the labour party steve
reed basically swerves this question i
mean it does say something about the
conservative party at this point i mean
a makeup of office like that
i think that's one thing that david
cameron really can take credit for is
that he was very clear that when he
became leader of the conservative party
that it was far too weighted towards
middle-aged white men of a certain
educational background and he pushed
really really hard with the a-list and i
think that the results of that the
fruits of that were actually in the
early stages of this um
campaign for the new leader you saw a
lot of people from ethnic minorities a
lot of women putting themselves forward
and i think that's a very positive thing
i mean you mentioned a change in style
from uh if liz trust wins to boris
johnson do you expect to see that office
of the prime minister that was brought
in under johnson basically that um
either we got rid of or changed in some
way
look i think that she's going to have to
run number 10 differently she's going to
have to be absolutely crystal clear that
it is a very very almost militaristic
operation if it's to be successful she's
got an entry that is flowing out the
door and on top of that the energy
crisis as well so unless there is
absolutely clarity of purpose and
absolute clarity of what the roles are
and how everything is operating it's not
going to work so i think there needs to
be an iron discipline there needs to be
a clear reality that we actually have to
start delivering two years is not a long
time in political terms really towards
the next election and she's got to get
some runs on the board she's well behind
in terms of um you know the polling at
the moment and in terms of who's the
best on most issues and she's got to
turn that around
quickly against very very significant
headwinds
and from the team you've seen who have
been suggested as being around this
trust if she does win it do you expect
to see an iron discipline from them or
we're just going to see them campaigning
continually
well look i hope that they will
understand that you know that they've
been through a campaign it's necessary
to use campaigning tactics and win and
that when they're in there they
understand that there is a big
difference between that and governing
there are trade-offs there are choices
to be made the most important thing is
to make sure that you are educating the
public
very very clearly in what you're doing
and why you're doing it and what the
difficulties are going to be i think in
politics a lot of politicians recently
shied away from the difficulties of
telling people leveling with people and
i think the british public showed during
corona virus when they're leveled with
they react very very well and very
positively i think liz trust will
probably level much more clearly with
the public but she's got to deliver